another demonstration and another arrest
for Alexei Navalny the years go by but
the pattern is always the same for
Navalny most protests end in jail with
weeks of administrative detention all in
all he spent almost 5 months in jail
over the past two years the charge
organising illegal protests the only
kind of protest possible in Russia say
his supporters and this is the work that
has made Navalny a household name in
Russia exposing what he says are the
corrupt personal fortunes of the
country's leaders and this in spite of a
near-total reporting ban on his
activities in the mainstream media this
mansion Navalny alleges is just one of
Vladimir Putin's private retreats way
beyond the means of the president's
officially declared earnings Prime
Minister Dmitry Medvedev and what
Navalny says his private palaces and
Italian vineyard is the subject of a
video that has been watched by more than
27 million people at a time when
ordinary Russians are being asked to
tighten their belts in public at least
Russia's leaders have long refused to
discuss the substance of Nirvana's
allegations or even to refer to him by
name but that seems to be changing in
September the head of Russia's National
Guard published a video message
challenging the valley to a duel and
promising to turn him into quote
mincemeat after no valleys team accused
the National Guard of widespread
corruption in the way it buys food for
its troops the only problem Navalny was
once again in jail at the time unable to
respond when he's not in jail Navalny is
able to mobilize his supporters like no
other leader of the Russian opposition
not just in Moscow but around the
country as public unrest grows over
government plans to raise the pension
age that's a threat the Kremlin seems to
be taking very seriously indeed
at the same time Russian authorities
seem unwilling to let Alexei Navalny
stay in jail for any considerable length
of time at the risk of turning him into
a prominent political prisoner for now
it seems his frequent trips to prison
are set to continue as here in September
where police were waiting to detain him
as soon as he left jail on another
charge